aaron and jeff back in uh as our our
next map is going to be a game mode that
we saw
at blizzcon line uh blizzcon in 2018
it seems like uh forever ago is a push
uh how has the game mode changed since
we last saw it
um we haven't made a lot of changes to
the mode
itself at least as far as like the big
rules go for it
but we've continued developing for it so
we
we have more than one push map
in development and i think we have more
than one that we'll even be looking at
today um so we're really committed to
the mode
um and we have a lot of fun playing this
thing
um i think the the interesting thing
about
push to me is it from the outside it
sort of looks like it's a riff
on payload um but there's something
about
having the the this robot move back and
forth
in the map that makes this very special
i almost think of push um more as a
moving control point
or or or a match of control
more than a a match of payload
um and you'll kind of see it the the
the mode can be really flanky um
so there's a lot of other heroes in here
that i think you can get play
and push and a lot of that has to do
with just the the bi-directional nature
of that robot
in the map and also because of how
quickly it moves
yeah now if you've never seen push
before uh there's a robot
in the middle both teams will come out
and kind of fight for it and then once
you get control you can start pushing
your barricade
towards uh the opponent's spawn it's the
name push guys uh
silosa you played it yeah i know apple's
con how did you find it then
i mean it seems like such a long time
ago when i played this at blizzcon
uh yeah it was pretty hectic i mean i i
will say though the uh
teams were horrendously unbalanced at
blizzcon and
i mean i think i had like siegel xqc uh
fran
and me were playing against random
people
it was a massacre i'll be honest i was
just afk
it didn't really matter but uh yeah it
was um
i can't wait to see it i just hey any
overwatch 2 news give it me i'll consume
that stuff i've
just given me how do you guys think it
feels now uh
in 5e5 because the last time we saw push
at blizzcon the
pvp was six on six does it play any
different you guys feel especially on
toronto
a little bit um so push has always been
maybe our most hectic mode or our most
dynamic
game mode and part of the reason for
that is the way these maps are designed
is we have a very um sort of like
wavy path that the robot travels on so
the objective is kind of always moving
back and forth and then we have a lot of
very direct routes across the map that
the players can take and because of that
it allows players to take a lot of
shortcuts circle around the enemy team
and it creates a lot of these flanking
opportunities
with five players there's just one less
person you kind of have to kind of keep
in the in in your mind's focus and and
kind of like worrying about where
they're going to show up at any time
um and so it settled down a little bit i
still think it has
that dynam dynamic nature that we've
always loved about push it's just a
little bit easier to
to kind of understand fast-paced i think
that's uh yeah that's kind of the way i
would put it like you have
uh a lot of the buildings you can go
through different types of routes you
can take
uh i'm i'm excited let's jump into map
number two this will be uh
toronto this will be push uh this is the
map that we actually saw uh back at
blizzcon
we all had a chance to play uh it was
awesome then
i'm excited to see some of like the the
flanking characters you can kind of get
like an overhead view of the map now and
see
you know your your tracers your genji's
on this type of map reaper is the one to
watch for i think all right
been tearing it up
so is this map the same as it was back
at blizzcon
um or has been any alterations to it um
it's
it's virtually the same um yeah
when we had the map at blizzcon it's um
it was definitely a work in progress and
it's still a work in progress now but
we've had the opportunity to add
additional polish and and art
resources into the map since then
all the maps just look so good uh i i
know i see stylosis face when we do the
fly through and he's just like smiling
and he's just like so giddy like
oh it's like it's so fun where i feel
like uh i feel like
push is going to add a different type of
element to the game
that like escort in uh hybrid like you
mentioned
like the payload oriented maps and i
think push kind of plays like that a
little bit
but there's so much more movement i feel
like than both of those
and just you take so many different
fights all over the map
uh and i also love the fact that you
just can't really tie
on this map i think uh one of the things
uh like about assault is that you can
you know you have like these like long
like battles and then it's a draw and
you're just like i wanted to
i mean i mean maybe even being okay
taking a loss there you know but like
uh this you definitely get a winner yeah
definitely and
i really like game modes where the
actual objective and the mechanics help
pace out the the speed of gameplay
it was really really hard for us to do
that with 2cp
you can have incredibly long matches in
2cp
and sometimes like really quick blowouts
and it just came down to what the two
teams were doing and
the game mode itself wasn't really doing
anything to enforce that the way it
might in control or in payload
uh and so with push um we have more of
that to where the game mode is actually
is actually
helping to control the length of the
match um and and the
the pace of the match yes uh
you see on the clock it's a eight minute
uh
clock right now so yeah it is uh it is
pretty fast i think it's definitely
intended with you know some of these are
behind this uh
it's a poor lumpy it gets taken out
right off right right right off the rim
lumpy was going on one of those flanks
didn't turn out uh
it didn't turn out so well so does the
uh the bottom lock right away
um it takes about 30 seconds for it to
unlock and the reason we do that
is we don't want a team to think that
there's a certain amount of
of pressure or to have all this pressure
to get to it as quickly as possible we
want you to be able to be
strategic with the way that you um
approach the bot in the middle of the
map
and it's it's very similar to the way
that control works
so we can see the the robot he's got a
name right
yeah his name is two
ah that's good it's uh we see uh
some genji play in action is yeah you
see like all the buildings you can kind
of come from players
you know up above to the side i think
you can definitely see that like
you know fast paced it it looks uh
way more like you can as a dps player
just kind of go off to the side make a
play
try and make it you see here they're
going right for the support yep
yeah and and the map there's still a
main path in push yeah
it's really important for us to have
that in all of our in all of our map
types
um but there are a lot of ways to get
around that and to get through it and
that's what creates a lot of these
opportunities
going for the remake kill can't blame
him
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i'm here i'm fixated on
the gameplay i think uh yeah i mean this
looks this looks really death match of
this does like
we're just you know they're just going
in they're having a a good old brawl and
then
obviously the as the mesh or the the
point is moving through the map it's
changing up every single time
and it's just to be honest it looks
fairly similar to
what i played back at blizzcon all those
years ago just with the
next tank it's yeah it's just yeah but
it's just more space i think that opera
yeah yeah
uh like i'm i'm somebody who
i play a ton of dps like and
i'm excited that maybe not everybody
will run around in like a death ball and
i'll be able to kind of like play tracer
and go off to the side and
make a play i noticed too uh the green
health
over lucio here what is that on the ui
now
actually you forgot about that so many
changes
i was like i was like uh sound barrier
doesn't give green health when i do it
right
so that's something um we're changing up
you know like everything's work in
progress it's possible to change
although we're pretty happy with it
right now
um this is a change to uh what we kind
of call overhealth this is a larger
system which is
you know in overwatch one you can have
over armor and over shields depending on
who's giving it to you much like you can
have normal health and shields
and armor um so you know once we started
getting into
trying to create clarity and make sure
the game is very readable
in all these senses you know like i
mentioned with the zenyatta's ui and
everything
um that came up too is like you know
it's possible to get
especially you get into like pve talents
and stuff like that your health bar can
get
really colorful really fast like you
could have you know
health and then armor and then shields
and then overhealth armor and shields
you could literally have
six segmented colored health and it was
like i can't even
understand what i'm looking at right now
this is like so insane
so it's we ended up condensing all of
the over over
health uh concepts into just one
concept now and so and it was kind of
kind of interesting other than
summer's emp over shields was more of
thematic thing than anything
because it doesn't it didn't regen like
normal shields because it's over health
doesn't have a
regeneration value so it was like it was
kind of nonsense anyway honestly
so now we kind of have everything
getting us into green health and it's
very understandable that
you know you see somebody with green and
you can see like okay that's not
you know that's over healthy it's either
going to drain or if i shoot through it
it can't be healed and stuff like that
so
um kind of helps uh clarify all that
poor tea is going to work out going back
and forth but uh
i noticed before there was like a circle
so is there like kind of uh
capture points like progress does that
change the respawns at all how does that
work on push
yeah it does so the robot starts in the
middle of the map and
it pushes those um like those red
barricades in front of it um and you can
use those to kind of like
in world see what your high water mark
is and if
if the robot's able to push it to the
checkpoint
um it will unlock a forward spawn room
for the the team that was able to do you
can kind of see it just off to the left
here behind reinhardt
so if the attacking team can push it
over there they'll unlock that spawn
point
and it gives them a big advantage in
order to kind of push through the rest
of the map
and then i assume when they're uh when
two starts moving the other direction i
guess it'd be
uh decides to start moving the other
direction uh
they would lose that forward spawn right
yeah
yep there is an additional detail there
it's two has to be pushed back to the
middle of the map
before you lose your forward spawn room
and we actually started it
the way um that you described it but a
lot of times the robot
could just move back and forth across
this one checkpoint
and it got like really chaotic and you'd
have no idea where you were gonna spawn
so we
we kind of gave you a grace period in
there or made it a little bit stickier
um by by forcing him to return to the
middle
yeah that's a good call i could imagine
if that was the case now yeah you would
have like
if i spawned this one second i would
spawn close and then like stylosis
spawns the next second and he's far away
yep and i mean that happens in overwatch
you know um
but it was just it was way too blatant
double bubble zarya is sick
she is incredible i love her it's
actually a pretty recent
thing you put checked it in but
it's no damage ram thought when she's
charged
yeah so you have the same bubbles you
have before but yeah they're both using
shared charges so yeah
we we found that because this increased
flexibility and how you use it she tends
to be a higher charge
more often uh i mean this is a good
example i guess
but uh so it's actually even a lot of
play tests
i could find myself like you know
sending a message to people what was
your average
energy would you say you're kind of
tearing it up
it looks so fun though i mean as
somebody who loves to play
zarya like uh i also can imagine the
people that i would play with on zarya
would just
automatically double bubble themselves
everybody
else yeah let's just run in and double
bubble ourselves but then you start to
think like
actually if i save two and you know
genji pulls out his blade on my team
i think if i double shield him and you
know i save that up
that's gonna be kind of ridiculous so
yeah i didn't even think of that like uh
yeah not just applying the two
bubbles to yourself but you could
because they shared the charge you could
theoretically like bubble a genji blade
and then bubble him again right
yeah so this is like as it just just
kind of recently put in um
coming off the back of the um april for
stuff
and seeing how we feel about it and it's
um
been pretty interesting i i i'm
certainly concerned about it in some
cases but it also needs some really
awesome play so
i'm kind of letting it rock for a while
and see see how it feels
work in progress but i i like the
progress on that one
so so uh ot how does the rule here work
i guess they have to push all the way to
the end or do they just have to
beat the time of the blue team they just
need to beat the time of the blue team
so
the the win condition for push is
whoever
has pushed it the furthest by the end of
time wins
or if you have it or if you're able to
push it all the way to the end of the
map you'll win instantly
so now they're unlocking their forward
spawn room right here
the tragedy strikes for the blue team
yeah they need to stay near the robot uh
i believe to keep pushing
yeah yeah right let's see so you can
have
you know the the the good old blunder
where everybody walks off the objective
and two just looks sad
i don't know what you're talking about
[Music]
yeah i imagine these games go right down
to the wire
uh definitely hectic there towards the
end this is this is going to be quite
good for overwatch league i'd imagine
this is i enjoyed that i really enjoyed
watching that
yeah i think uh